Das UFO kommt! Das UFO kommt! Das UFO kommt! Be ready! Be ready! Gut. Das war die Anmoderation. So! Gut, dann können wir ja anfangen. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu dieser klassischen Folge von Das Podcast UFO. Wir sind jetzt wieder, Moment, kurz nachdenken, wir sind jetzt wieder abgehoben, nachdem wir letzte Woche in Berlin gelandet waren. Kurz als Zwischenstopp an der Tanke, schön an der Shell, ein paar Snickers mitgenommen, schön Kit-Kat-Chunky. Eiskonfekt mitgenommen und dann abgehoben wieder, haben gut günstig getankt und sind wieder gelandet. Falsche Ausfahrt genommen leider, ein bisschen gedreht, da hat TomTom ein bisschen versagt. Ich finde es mittlerweile pervers, dass es in gewissen Läden nur noch die KitKat-Chunky-Varianten gibt, nicht mehr das Original-KitKat-Chunky. Ich finde, wir hatten genug KitKat, KitKat hat sich gedacht, Leute, es reicht auch mal jetzt ein bisschen mehr. Dann gibt es die Chunky Peanut Butter. Chunky, genau, dann Chunky. Und das ist eine der wenigen Produkte in Deutschland, wo man sagt, man hat sich für Peanut Butter entschieden. Viele Produkte trauen sich das nicht, den Schritt. Ich halte das für einen Fehler. M&Ms ja, hier sehr populiert, populiert, M&Ms Peanut, aber nicht M&Ms Peanut Butter. Aber das ist ja auch so, es gab erst KitKat, dann gibt es KitKat Chunky, dann hat KitKat Chunky seinen Vater verdrängt sozusagen, KitKat raus, dann wieder die beiden Neffen, KitKat Chunky Peanut Butter, KitKat Chunky Kokosnuss, KitKat Chunky White. Und die haben wieder um ihren Vater herausgestochen. Es ist griechische Tragödien, spielen sich da ab in den Süsswarenabteilungen. Bald wird man das doch lesen, weil statt Iphigenia auf Taurus zum Beispiel Titel wie Ähm Warte, warte, warte. Wir machen es doch nicht einfach. Warte. Okay, Crossover aus Süssigkeiten und griechischer Tragödie. Gut, ich war nur bei KitKat, ich habe es mir auch ein bisschen schwerer gemacht. Iphigenia auf Tic Tac, Iphigenia auf Twix. Ja. Da fallen sich keine anderen griechischen Triodien ein. Die Hure von Bounty? Die Wander-Bounty? Ihr merkt, wir sind in Form, wir sind nicht ausgelaugt, wir sind nicht durch die ganzen Reisestress ein bisschen down, nein, uns geht's gut. Überhaupt nicht. Es hat echt viel Spaß gemacht, das war die erste Folge, wo wir uns aus unserem Kämmerlein gewagt haben. Jetzt haben wir uns wieder dafür, als ob wir es ein bisschen überkompensieren müssen, wieder ein neues Kämmerlein gesperrt. Es ist noch ein bisschen enger, die Wände sind noch ein bisschen feuchter, es riecht noch ein bisschen mehr nach, man weiß nicht, abgestandenes After-Aid oder so, unangenehm. Das ist, also einerseits, es hat hier so einen Kaffeegeruch im Raum, und Kaffee hat, also ich hab's gerochen und hab sofort gesagt Kuchen, weil bei mir sofort Kaffee und Kuchen, so dieses alte Oma-Ding, wo man dann Kuchen gettet hat. Es riecht wie bei Oma am Sonntag, finde ich. Genau, ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch die neue Linie von Chanel. Chanel immer eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf und Oma am Sonntag und Opa unterm Arm. Also jedenfalls für jeden Tag. Opa unterm Arm, Oma am Sonntag, Oma in der Kirche, das war es mit Oma. Aber das ist mir aufgefallen, als ich mal lange Zeit in einem Altenheim war und da durch die Korridore... Lange Zeit, wie lange warst du da? Schon zehn Minuten. Gute sechs Minuten. Ja, und da bin ich so durch die Korridore geirrt und die haben ja an, also zumindest in dem Altenheim, in dem ich war, haben die an jeder Ecke After-Aid. Die hatten immer After-Aid, weil es anscheinend ganz gut zu essen ist, wenn man keine Zähne mehr hat. Man könnte überall auch diese Desinfektionsapparate hinsetzen. Nein, die haben gesagt, komm, wir gehen einfach überall. Eine schöne Urne. Nee, Wissenschaftler haben herausgefunden, dass ältere Leute länger und glücklicher leben, wenn überall so eine After-Aid-Notfallpackung steht. Aber seitdem betrachte ich After-Aid auch anders, weil After-Aid war für mich immer so dieses edle, englische das hat Churchill geknabbert, als er die Bombenangriffe auf Dresden geplant hat, das war so, oh, toll. Ja, das hat so was Hochkulturelles, was sehr kultiviert ist. Mama, Oma hat schon wieder die After-Aid-Packung hinter der Tür versteckt, so wie Alkoholiker, die immer diese Whisky-Flaschen und Biere im Raum verstecken. Wo man einfach nicht übersehen kann, ja gut, Oma hat keine Zähne. Ja, Dorn, After-Aid, klar. Und das hat für mich die ... Suppe, After-Aid, zack, fertig, satt. Ich fand schon die Aldi-After-Aids eine Beleidigung. Das war für mich wirklich so meine Sets-Beleidigung. After Seven? War für mich einfach nicht mehr einzeln, obwohl die, muss man ganz ehrlich zugeben, ein bisschen geiler sind, weil dünner. Oh, echt jetzt? Ja, dünner, zart. Sorry. Fällt mir das Mikrofon aus. Ist immer die Frage, lieber dicker oder dünner? Manche Düssigkeiten sind besser, wenn sie noch ein bisschen dicker, siehe KitKat Chunky, andere sind ein bisschen besser, wenn sie dünner sind. Ich finde, es gab so eine Zeit, wo man rumexperimentiert hat mit Essen als Kind, Esspapier zum Beispiel, wo man dachte, Papier kann ich nicht essen. Und dann ist es so clever, von der Lebensmittelindustrie zu sagen, wisst ihr was, hier ist Esspapier und ihr könnt es essen. Viel Spaß, ihr könnt drauf schreiben, ihr könnt drauf essen, ihr könnt es verschicken, ihr könnt es primär essen. Bitte esst es einfach nur, macht keinen anderen Scheiß damit. Deswegen auch der beliebte Werbespruch, jetzt kann man Papier essen, ess Papier. Warum gibt's nicht da mehr, einfach Essstuhl? Ja, also man kann ja auch mit Zucker kann man gut Flaschen machen, Zuckerflaschen, wo man sich auch fragt, warum nicht mehr so was, mehr Gegenstände, die man auch essen kann. Also dann so Cola in der Zuckerflasche, dass sie sich auflöst. Nicht schnell, es ist einfach nur eine Pfütze Cola auf dem Tisch. Was ich auch immer geil finde, ist bei Milka Tender, das sind ja diese kleinen Riegel. Du kennst dich so gut aus. Wir verlieren Leute erstens, weil es ist nicht relatable. Jeder kennt Tender. Du bist zu sehr in dem Schokoladensumpf drin. Ich muss es googeln, Milka Tender. Milka Tender ist richtig geil, weil da hast du so eine Milchcreme und so einen Biskuitteig. Ich bin ja eh großer B Biskuit-Fan. Oh, das sind diese Dinge, wo ich mir denke, Milka hat sich verrannt. Wirklich? Back to the roots, einfach Klassik Alpenmilchschokolade. Kill the Alpen, einfach Milchschokolade, ein bisschen Vollmilchschokolade und das könnte gut. Macht einen Hasen zu Ostern, macht einen Weihnachtsmann zu Weihnachten. Hat das jemand verstanden, was der Unterschied ist zwischen Vollmilch und Alpenmilchschokolade? Also es gibt ja mal die hellblaue und die dunkelblaue Berittersport. Keine Ahnung. Nee, und bitter, Edelbitter. Richtig, es gibt viele verschiedene Sorten Rittersport, das hast du gut erkannt, Stefan. Nee, weil das auch eine reine Schokolade. Um diese beiden. Ja, es klang jetzt aus, wenn du das so formulierst, das ist jetzt ziemlich dumm, was ich gesagt habe. Worauf ich bei den Hauswild ist, dass Milka auf die Idee gekommen ist, hey, pass auf, wenn das Geile ist klein, ist es auch geil gross. Und wir machen Tender gross. Und es gibt Tender auch in der Kuchengrösse, halt wie so diese Bisküttrolle Kuchen, so dass man das als Kuchen, das ist so eine geile Idee, ähnlich geil, wie Haribo Colorado gesagt hat, die sind geil und gross, also warum nicht geil klein und haben Colorado nochmal in der neuen Packung kleiner, alles ist kleiner, so dass du halt wirklich so eine Handvoll Colorado Zeug reinschütten kannst, war glaube ich 2013 Produkt des Jahres und das heißt für mich, ich gucke immer, was das Produkt des Jahres ist.
Was ist dieses Jahr das Produkt des Jahres?
Weiß man noch nicht, kommt im September erst raus.
Im September erst raus?
Im September, klar.
Komischer Zeitraum, um das bekannt zu geben, weil es kann auch viel passieren, also 2018 kann auch viel bereithalten im Zeitraum Oktober bis Dezember. Wir können ja mal ein bisschen sammeln und dann können wir schon vor der offiziellen Produkt des Jahres Verkündigung sagen, was es ist. Okay, unsere Top 5 Produkte des Jahres. Wer muss anfangen? Ich muss immer anfangen, damit ich selber die einzig habe, oder wie war das? Ja, also hier ist Nummer fünf. Fün... Produkt. Es gibt so viele Produkte. Produkt des Jahres. Auf Platz fünf. Muss es an diesem Jahr rausgekommen sein? Du hast die Kategorie aufgemacht. Kann ich es zurücknehmen? Ja, ich muss den mit zurücknehmen. Geo-Antrag zurücknehmen. Alles klar. Und ich dachte mir, warum machen das nicht andere Süßigkeiten?
Also stell dir mal vor, Duplokuchen. Ein Riesenduplo, wo du halt wie so einen Kuchen so Schichten abschneidest und als Kuchen verzehrst. Ich finde, der Kontext ist entscheidend, weil Baumkuchen, Stichwort Baumkuchen, gibt es ja normalerweise zu kaufen im Supermarkt sehr klein. Das sind einfach diese kleinen Ringe, die sind so sagen wir mal groß wie hoch wie eine Tasse und so breit wie zwei Tassen.
Und dieser Baumkuchen ist aber eigentlich, der Original Baumkuchen ist unglaublich lang, der ist so drei Meter lang und dann schneidet man die locker durch und dann hält man eine Tasse daneben und dann nimmt man genau die, allem, dann denke ich mir, wenn man das dann sieht, seitdem finde ich den Baumkuchen an sich interessanter, weil der von etwas Größerem kommt. Der wurde wie so ein Stück Fleisch aus einem Rind geschnitten, wurde einfach dieser Baumkuchen von einem grösseren Stück Baumkuchen, von einem riesigen Stamm wurde der genommen. Aber er wurde dann erst mit Schokolade überzogen. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, die werden schon in der großen Form mit Schokolade überzogen.
Ja, aber das müsste ja oben offen sein.
Ja, ist es nicht oben offen?
Nee.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau.
Baumkuchen, weil es aussieht wie ein Stamm, oder was?
Weil es Schichten hat, weil es aussieht wie diese Stirnstruktur. Ach so, wenn man es aufschneidet, weiß man, wie alt der Baumkuchen war.
Ja.
Es hat gerade keinen Stamm, es ist innen hohl.
Baumkuchen, weil es keinen Stamm hat. So wie Little John, weil der gross war. Clever. Ja, Leute, Wörter haben Bedeutungen. Bitte haltet euch mal einfach daran. Nee, aber das ist einfach so ein grosses Snickers. Stell dir das mal vor, so ein wirklich grosses, so ein handarmdickes Snickers. Ich glaube, ich stelle mir dieses Phänomen des grossen Snickers mindestens dreimal am Tag vor.
Einfach so, wenn man mal
denkt, ich habe mich
jetzt gerade übergegangen, mich sehr gut zu ernähren.
Ich habe immer so eine große, acht Liter
Wolvingflasche am Tisch stehen
und trinke sehr viel.
Wie viele Tassen sind das pro Tag?
Gut, zwei Tassen.
Und dann muss ich auch häufig zum Klo gehen.
Und dann denke ich mir, wann, wie oft ist es, also
es gibt nämlich dieses Bit vom Comedian John Mulaney, der meinte, der wollte Xanax sich holen beim Arzt. Das ist eine Droge, ich glaube zum gut einschlafen oder sowas. Und zum gute Laune machen und gut einschlafen. Und da hat er, die kann man sich einfach verschreiben lassen, wenn du halt Ärzte bescheisst so ein bisschen. Und dann hat er die klassische Ausrede, die man dann nimmt, benutzt, ich gehe zu oft auf Toilette. Dann hat er gefragt, wie oft denn?
Dann meinte er, elf Mal.
Und der Arzt ist ausgerastet, weil er meinte,
das ist viel zu viel.
So, jetzt denke ich mir aber, wenn ich diese Flasche Wolvik
am Tag leer trinke, und das ist
wirklich sehr viel, dann gehe ich bestimmt
auch sieben Mal aufs Klo.
Aber ist es dann immer noch ungesund?
Weil ich habe ja den Grund auch, warum ich eher
aufs Klo, warum ich so aufs Klo bin. Man geht ja nicht nur aufs Klo, um, sage ich mal, aufs Klo zu gehen. Nee, auch Lifestyle-Gründe, klar. Lifestyle-Gründe, auch einfach mal ein bisschen Zeit für sich zu haben. Von daher zählt das auch, oder muss man das dem Arzt dann auch sagen? Kennst du diese Lifestyle-Gründe, Lifestyle-Grund aufs Klo gehen, Nummern? Und dann war davor ein Kollege auf dem Klo und es stinkt, und man kann, also man weiß nicht, was man machen soll, weil man will den Leuten, die das gesehen haben, dass du reingehst, auch nicht das Gefühl geben, dass du sofort wieder rausgehst. Also musst du Zeit aufverbringen, das ist unangenehm. Ah, das ist schwierig. Sozialflucht. Hast du, bist du nervös, wenn du im Zug die Tür aufmachen musst? Ja, wenn ich der Erste bin, holy shit. Oh mein Gott. Und man wird nervös, kalter Schweiss läuft einem runter, und man drückt drauf, und man weiss, natürlich weiss, ich bin ein erwachsener Mann, dass es erst geht, wenn das grüne Licht angeht. Aber natürlich machst du da Vorstellungen, drückst du schon ein paar Mal da drauf, weil du denkst, wenn ich die Millisekunden danach draufdrücke, dann werden die Leute hinter mir sauer. Ja, vor allem, also ich glaube, du denkst es an eine S-Bahn,
ich denke aber auch an Züge,
wo man dann wirklich dann also wirklich
mit Schwung und mit Kraft die Tür aufheben
muss und sowas. Und da gibt es dann immer
auch die Situation, dass der Zug einfährt,
hält, aber die Tür noch nicht entriegelt.
Und du willst nicht der Depp sein, der dann
drumrum rüttelt und nicht checkt,
dass sie einfach noch nicht entriegelt sind.
Du willst aber auch nicht der Trottel sein, der als letzter die Tür aufmacht, sodass alle hinter dir stecken bleiben.
Das heißt, du bist in diesem ganz, ganz feinen Zwischenraum zwischen, ich muss schon früh genug rütteln, weil du willst ja auch nicht rütteln und dann merken, geht noch nicht und dann nochmal rütteln.
Du musst früh genug, aber nicht zu spät. Das heißt, der Trick ist durchatmen, tief einatmen, ausatmen und denken wie der Zug. Eins werden dem Zug. Ist es schon entriegelt, ist es noch nicht entriegelt? Ist die Tür vielleicht defekt, ist die Tür nicht defekt? Denken wie der Zug. Anfahren, bremsen. Stehen bleiben. Bei Dormagen rechts. Denken wie der Zug, R1. Reservierungen werden nicht angezeigt. Stimmt. Bahn, Komfort, Kunden, finden trotzdem überall Platz. Erste Klasse heute ohne Heizung. Es geht immer um die fucking Bahn, ey. Zweite Klasse mit zu viel Heizung, ja. Wir sparen uns die Gigs. Obwohl man auch sagen muss, also es gibt ja, sag ich mal, die Bahn ist ja, sag ich mal, ein interessantes Unternehmen, weil es gibt einmalseits die krasse, moderne. Du kannst mein Bild nicht abbrechen und sagen, jetzt drehen schon wieder über die Bahn, um dann ein neues Bahnbit zu beginnen. Was ist das denn? Comedy Bitch Move. Die heißt Bitch Verschisse? Bitch Move? Bit? Bitch? Ja, das war die Idee. Nein, war nicht die Idee, du hast vielleicht ja gar nicht erkannt. Sorry, ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen bei deinem hilarious Bahn-Bit.
Es gibt einmal eins als die moderne Bahn, die irgendwie mit App und mit irgendwie Infrarot und QR-Code und krass und moderne Züge.
Ultraschall, Röntgenstrahlen, die haben es drauf.
Laser und mit grünem Zug und Graffiti auf dem Haar.
Und dann gibt es die fucking Oldschool-Bahn.
Ja, wo du das Gefühl hast, dass gleich die Frau aus Harry Potter vorbeikommt und dir Süßigkeiten anbietet. Ja, und was für mich ausdrückt, das sind ja glaube ich auch zwei völlig unterschiedliche Mitarbeitergruppen. Die neuen, modernen High Energy, das sind dann junge, kecke Frauen, die irgendwie Pferdeschwanz und dann wirklich alles durchorganisiert. und die Alten sind eher so die Mitte-Fünfzig-Männer,
die halt dann auch noch bei ihren alten Loks, wenn die anfahren, noch so in der Tür stehen. Und die Tür ist offen während der Zug fährt. Da denkst du einfach, wow, das sind die alten Cowboys. Die haben damals das Land entdeckt und das gebaut. Die haben das alles entdeckt. Die Gesichter sind dreckig, ihr riecht nach Schweiß, solche Leute sollen meine Bahn fahren. Und da auch immer so, wie ist es, wie lang wartet man in der Tür, weil es ja mega geil. Du fährst in der Bahnsteige, da lagen alle sehen dich und du stehst in der Tür. Du schiebst noch so an, wie so Müllmänner, denen noch so mithelfen anzufangen. Finde ich ganz gut eigentlich. Und das ist immer so der Moment, wo ich denke, lernen die das? So von wegen so, okay, wenn du einsteigst, fahr noch so gute drei Sekunden bei offener Tür mit und dann schau noch so raus, ist alles okay, du könntest es eh nicht mehr hier gehen, es ist eh egal. Betriebsblick nennt man das. Und dann einfach nochmal reinsteigen. Oder ist es einfach so ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, dass man das einfach macht, weil es geil ist? Ah, gute Frage. Oder kriegt man sowas gesagt in der Schulung zum Schaffner? Ich glaube, da wird explizit gesagt, man soll das nicht machen. Man soll aus Sicherheitsgründen die Türen lieber ein bisschen zu früh zu machen. Und nicht die Hand raushalten, um nochmal allen High Five zu geben. Allen am Bahnsteig High Five geben, das Kind klauen, so ein Kind aus den Händen, aus den Armen der Mutter schnappen und mit der, die dann erst bei Hamm Westfalen ablassen. Bist du früher mal Fahrrad gefahren auf dem Land und an seinem Kornfeld vorbei und hast dann so deine Hand und hast dann so deine Hand über die Ähren strebt? Du meinst wie so ein Indie-Film, so ein cool Indie-Song? Ja, ja. Oder halt auch so, ich hab mir da immer so Tour de France vorgestellt, dass ich Tour de France Fahrradfahrer bin und die Leute sind so die Hände und dann die Getreidesachen und dann klatscht die Hände. Und Leute rufen die los zu. Ankommen ist nicht alles. Es ist nicht schlimm,
wenn du nicht ankommst.
Bist du gedopt? Ja, dann hören wir auf zu klatschen,
dann finde ich nicht mehr cool. Nein, ich bin nicht gedopt.
Okay.
Nee, aber wie im Indie-Film, wo man viele Sachen,
ich glaube, das macht man nur, weil die
Regisseure und Writer dieses Films schon mal
an einen Indie-Film geguckt haben,
als ob die ihre Kinder damit verbracht haben, die Reben, ja,ren, nee, die Kornspitzen mit den Fingerspitzen zu betatschen oder halt irgendwie im See nackt zu baden oder sowas. Macht man das? Weiß ich nicht. Also meine Kinder bestanden zu selten daraus. Also auch dieses Auf-Dächer-Steigen ist auch so ein Ding. Macht man das? Auf wie vielen Dächern warst du in deinem Leben? Selten auf Dächern. Ganz selten auf Dächern. Ich bin mir auch immer nicht sicher. So Ziegel, wie fest sind die da befestigt? Da kommt ein Windstoß und dann ist manchmal gar nicht mehr so bedeckt, das ganze Dach. Also da kommen dann schon manchmal auch welche runter. Und dann denke ich mir, vielleicht sind die nicht so fest, wie man denkt. Aber auf der anderen Seite, die meisten Windstöße hält es ja aus. Wir kommen in ein Terrain, wo ich, muss ich zugeben, nicht mehr so viel Ahnung habe. Zurück zu den Ähren. Ja, zurück zu Reben und Ähren. Tatsächlich hat neulich ein Kollege von mir und dir nicht mehr so richtig, weil du jetzt keinen Job mehr hast. Aber der hat jetzt, der macht einen Pilotenschein. Und der ist schon sehr, sehr weit. Und er hat jetzt, neulich kam er dann so rein, er kam ein bisschen zu spät zur Arbeit, meinte, ja, ich habe gerade meinen Test bestanden, ey, boah, ich habe es so gerade bestanden, alter, geil, wie man es aus der Schule kennt, so, ich habe einen Test bestanden, alter, und er hatte dieses, ja genau, dieses, ich habe es gerade bestanden, ich bin Rebell, ich habe nicht viel gelernt, ich habe es so gerade durchgehobengehoben, einmal so, yo, es war so knapp und er hat dieses, wie man das aus der Schule kennt, dieses, oh geil, sauber, du bist echt, du bist mein Mann so erwartet, aber es kam eher zurück so ein, okay, bitte flieg nie wieder, bitte steig nie wieder in den Flugzeug rein, du hast es nicht verdient zu fliegen. Und natürlich fällt einem dann ein, dass man von Piloten erwartet, dass sie keinen Fehler machen sollten.
Und dass sie auch einfach bessere Menschen sind, die sich nicht so durch ihr Leben durchwiesen. Richtig, und natürlich haben die auch bei Tests gemogelt, auch mal den Spicker rausgeholt, die Hand geschrieben, Lehrer erpresst, all das. Ja, weil die Piloten haben schön den Spickzettel im Dekolleté verschwinden lassen, diese ganzen Tricks, die man halt so kennt. Ja, aber das will man eben nicht. Man erwartet von diesem Menschen, besser zu sein, das alles bitte zu wissen. Ist auch wie so ein Arzt oder so, wo du beim Medizinabschluss dann so ... Alter, ich hatte keine Ahnung, ich hab überhaupt nicht gelernt, aber irgendwie hab ich's geschafft, Alter! Ich hab's nicht geschafft, Leute! Jetzt war kein Geil! Und niemand high-fifed, niemand high-fifed. Und dann hab ich auch mal so ein Video gesehen von zwei Piloten, da gibt's das Pilot'sye, das ist ein YouTube-Channel, die die ganze Zeit die Arbeit von Piloten zeigen und halt für Nerds kann man sich das dann kaufen und da kannst du schön acht Stunden Frankfurt, New York dir angucken, wirklich in real time, 15 DVDs, Set, kannst du dann gucken, wie die dann da fliegen und wie die nichts machen, ausser den Autopiloten beobachten. Und dann gibt es eine Ausgabe, die gibt es auch bei YouTube, wie zwei Piloten ein Feuer haben in einer Turbine. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Simulator, man kann es aber nicht so genau erkennen, ich glaube, das ist ein Simulator. Und dann spielt das Szenario durch, was passiert, wenn ein Triebwerk Feuer fängt. Und dann denkt man ja, die wissen jetzt genau, was sie tun, das haben sie ja gelernt. Die wissen genau, was sie tun, die machen, drücken die Knöpfe, gibt ja viele Knöpfe, die wissen schon, wofür die alle gut sind und so weiter. Stellt sich raus, die wissen nicht, was dann man da macht. Die haben keine Ahnung, was dann passiert. Dafür haben die nie gelernt. Die holen dann, wie man das kennt, wenn man eine komische Leuchte beim Auto leuchtet, wie man dann ins Handschuhfach greift und dann die User's Manual rausholt und dann nachschlägt einfach. Genauso lief es bei denen auch. Ja, dann schlagen die einfach nach, was dann passiert. Und da gibt es halt ein Kapitel. B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, Bchaden, Katastrophe, sind wir bei K? Sind wir schon bei K? Ich weiß es nicht. Wo soll ich nachschlagen? Ruf den Tower an. Und dann haben die dieses Kapitel aufgeschlagen und suchen dann danach und dann steht dann drin, was sie machen müssen. Und dann die Korpiote fragen dann auch sowas wie, ist es der Knopf da? Und man denkt sich, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein. Ihr solltet wissen, was ihr da macht. Aber es sind auch nur Menschen. Und das System ist einfach nur sehr sicher, weil du halt einfach, du hast ein Problem und alle Probleme stehen in diesem Buch. Das ist ein dickes Buch. Ich glaube, es ist sogar ein digitales Buch, weil erinnere mich nicht daran. Aber ich glaube, es ist ein digitales, iPad-mäßig. Das ist ein wertes Passwort. Genau. Oh, jetzt müssen die Puck eingeben. Hat jemand die Puck? Mobiltan, ist es dein Ernst? Wenn alle Passagiere kurz aufstehen könnten und unter ihren Sitz gucken könnten, ob da irgendwo ein Zettel mit der Puck liegt.
Und dann tatsächlich haben die keine Ahnung, aber alles steht da drin.
Und dann hat der Kollege gesagt, er versteht nicht, und das ist auch ein großes Rätsel,
die Flugsicherheit ist extrem gut und der Standard ist extrem hoch, weil sie Piloten nicht als Künstler begreifen, wiezte zum beispiel sondern einfach als handwerker die nachschlagen können im zweifelfall ärzte und vor allem chirurgen bei ops haben das nicht die könnten ja auch einfach dieses perfekte ipad haben wo je nachdem was passiert okay da kommt gerade so eine blutfontäne aus seiner nase raus mal nachschlagen bbb und dann können die nachschlagen, B, B, L, und dann können die es nachschlagen und dann steht ja genau, was sie machen müssen.
Bei jedem Problem für die Flugsicherheit ist das geklärt, bei Ärzten nicht, warum haben die sowas nicht?
Und dann hat er gesagt, das ist tatsächlich so, weil die Ärzte sich dagegen wehren, weil die sich tatsächlich als Künstler verstehen so ein bisschen und dem wird man den Freiraum lassen.
Und der Doktor so und so macht das halt so und der Doktor so und so stellt dann Tampon in die N. Und der andere, der lässt das Problem ganz in Ruhe, weil der Körper heilt ja am besten von allein und so. Also da gibt es sehr viele Auffassungen, das fand ich total spannend. Also Fakt ist, Piloten haben keine Ahnung, was sie tun, aber sind immer noch besser als Ärzte. Sind zum Glück keine Künstler zumindest. Sind zum Glück verstehen sie sich nicht auch noch als Künstler. Was mit Köchen? Sind das Künstler oder Handwerker? Oh, Künstler. Künstler? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das schmeckt ja immer ein bisschen anders. Aber ich glaube, bei Piloten kann man auch eher vorausahnen, was für Probleme es gibt, weil du bist ja im luftleeren Raum, also im luftigen Raum. Im vollen Raum, also sehr viel, es ist selten so viel Luft. Man ist im Luftraum, glaube ich, kann man sagen. Ja, kann man wirklich. Aber es ist ja relativ vorhersehbar, was da kommt. Weil ein Vogel kann reinfliegen in die Turbine, Turbine brett. Wie detailliert ist das? Das ist halt welcher Vogel. Ein Condor ist in Triebwerk B3 geflogen. Aber ich glaube, als Arzt kann gut sein, dass jemand eine Krankheit hat, ja, ich habe hier so grüne Punkte. Ihr habt noch nie in meinem Leben gehört. Ciao, keine Ahnung. Das glaube ich nicht. Und da musst du improvisieren. Aber als Flugzeugmann, als Piloto, was soll da kommen? Da kommt dann irgendwie, ja, jetzt brennt dieser Teil des Flugzeugs oder dieser Teil des Flugzeugs. Ja, es gibt eine ähnliche Anzahl Dinge, die brennen können. Ja gut, und vor allem ist es ja, sag ich mal, Technik, die ist ja nicht so komplex wie ein menschlicher Körper. Ein menschlicher Körper kann jetzt plötzlich einfach grüne Punkte haben, aber du hast nicht plötzlich grüne Punkte auf dem Trieb. Ja, aber hier geht es ja auch um die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass grüne Punkte auftreten plötzlich. Ja, diesen Blick kenne ich, diesen Blick, das ist der, wir schieben den Popschuss kurz weg, klopfen aufs Mikrofon, um zu gucken, ob nicht alles schon aus war die ganze Zeit. Nee, nee, alles gut. Alles gut? Alles gut. Hoffe ich. Aber das fand ich, das hat mich echt zum Nachdenken angeregt, dieser Satz, ich habe den Test, meinen Pilotentest gerade so bestanden. Gerade so, umbiegen undchen bist du würdest du dich eher als künstler oder als handwerker bezeichnen künstler ja ja also zum handwerker also nicht aus so einer suffisanten ich sehe mich hier als künstler und werfe meinen schal kurz zurück art sondern eher aus so einer ich bin zu faul um das handwerk zu lernen art also man könnte sich ja auch jetzt so comedy handwerk drauf schaffen. Und ich werde auch gefragt, ob ich irgendwie Bücher empfehlen kann für Comedy, zum Schreiben und so weiter. Und ich habe dann auch ein paar Bücher auf Lager, die man so raushaut, die ich auch mal gelesen habe, aber die habe ich ja nicht durchgearbeitet. Das sind ja Bücher, wo man dann auch tendenziell auch einen Monat lang damit verbringen kann, das durcharbeiten kann, aber habe ich doch nie. Bei Comedy lernt man nicht aus Büchern, sondern aus Leid und Schmerz und Enttäuschung. Du trägst selten Schals, ne? Ja, selten Schals. Gar nicht so, wegen Workout auch, oder? Weil du deine Schultern zeigen willst? Ich will meine Schultern zeigen, ich will meinen kräftigen Halsmuskel der Schulzeigen und es kratzt. Aber du ballerst ja wirklich ein bisschen, ne? Nee, ich habe schon seit einem halben Jahr nicht mehr trainiert, bestimmt. Ach so. Nee, ich hab mich ein bisschen aufgeregt, also es kam zu so ein paar Zwischenfällen irgendwie, da wurde ich dann doof angeguckt von Leuten, weil ich dann halt meine Stange in die Luft halte und dann hat man hier und da so ein bisschen Gekicher gehört, Gekicher und Geschnatter und dann dachte ich... Weil du immer noch ohne Gewichte trainierst. Weil ich immer noch ohne Gewichte trainiere, Rücken schonend, mit Eigengewicht, meine Arme. Nur die Hände nach oben. Und dann habe ich mich auch aufgeregt, weil, also folgender Fall, liebe Juristen, Kollegen unter euch, mein Fitnessstudio wurde übernommen. Fitnessstudio A wurde übernommen von Fitnessstudio-Konzern B. Fitnessstudio-Konzern B ist aber billiger als A. Die Preise sind aber geblieben. Ich habe neulich da mal gegoogelt, ob das, wie die Preise bei B sind, vielleicht sind die ja tatsächlich mittlerweile so teuer, nein, Preise B sind billiger als die von A. Ich bezahle weiterhin die Preise von A, obwohl ich das in einem Fitnessstudio von B bin. Und da habe ich da angerufen und habe gesagt, Leute, könnt ihr das mal bitte sein lassen und mir einfach vernünftig die Preise abziehen, die ihr verlangt, weil ihr B seid. Und dann meinte die, ja, aber dann haben sie die Kinderbetreuung nicht mehr drin, dann haben sie den Kaffeeautomaten nicht mehr drin, wo man sich auch Fragen stellt. Also wer in meinem Alter braucht eine Kinderbetreuung, also vor allem wer geht überhaupt, wer geht ins Fitnessstudio, um seine Kinder in der Kinderbetreuung im Fitnessstudio abzugeben? Und haben die dann auch so kleine Handeln, so kleine Äntchen anhandeln. Die haben kleine Handeln und laufen auf so in Hamsterrädern, laufen sie da rum. Ja, und dann Kaffeeautomat, Kaffeeautomat, das ist das Letzte, was ich brauche, wenn ich im Fitnessstudio bin. Da habe ich gesagt, die beiden sagen, können Sie mir einfach streichen, oder können Sie mir einen billigen Preis geben, und das wollten sie dann nicht tun. Und jetzt denke ich mir, habe ich vielleicht nicht sogar recht, wenn ich da einfach kündigen könnte, aber naja, im Mai läuft eh mein Vertrag aus. Und dann wird EMS-Training betrieben. Oh, das mit den Elektroden. Elektroschockern. Genau. Ja, aber ich finde, ja, ich finde, du hast es völlig richtig gemacht, weil ich finde, du hast jetzt den perfekten Körper, weil man will ja auch nicht übertrainiert sein, so ich glaube, das ist ja eine Angst, die man auch immer hat. Nicht den perfekten Körper, ich habe zugenommen lassen. Vor allem, ich finde immer, wenn man die, also man will ja breite Schultern, du hast ja gesagt, du willst breite Schultern, damit du endlich als deine Männlichkeit endlich wahrgenommen werden. Obwohl ich gar nicht genau tecke, was das heißt, breite Schultern, weil ich meine deine, das ist ja festgelegt von den Schulterknochen oder was auch immer, aber ich finde auch ab einem gewissen Punkt, also Bodybuilder oder so, die wirklich Schultermuskulatur haben, ich finde, ab einem gewissen Punkt wirkt Schultermuskulatur ratlos. Die haben dann so dieses ... Ja, die ist hochgezogen. Dieses wie Schulterzuckende, hochgezogene Schulter. Dieses, hey, weißt du, wo mein Proteinshake ist? Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Weißt du es wirklich nicht, oder sind deine Schultern nur so hoch? Die wirken immer so, ich habe keine Ahnung, Leute. Ja, und dann achtet man darauf.
Irgendwann erreichen die auch das Stadium, wo es aussieht, als ob ein weiterer Mensch aus denen herauswächst. Weil die Schultern, dann gibt es quasi nicht mehr die Schultern und dann kommt der Kopf, sondern dann kommt so eine Art Treppe. Weil dann fängt diese grossartige Halsmuskulatur an, auf der dann der Kopf liegt. Das sieht aus, als ob oben aus diesem, wie so ein, ist das nicht Lex Luthor oder so? Oder so ein Exoskelett und da raus guckt dann so ein normaler Mensch, der den anderen Menschen kontrolliert. Also ein dünner, schmächtiger Typ, der aus dem Muskelmann rauskommt und den so kontrolliert. Hat man nicht auch irgendwann zwei Körper, dass man so krass trainiert, dass man dann sich teilen kann oder so? Das wäre geil. Das finde ich gut. Zellteilung. Und dann ist man zwei Leute, die nicht mehr so gut aussehen. Ich finde, du hast das völlig richtig gemacht, Stefan. Du hast dich trainiert auf einen Punkt, wo du, sag ich mal, respektabel bist, wo dich niemand mehr einfach so angeht, wo man sagt, okay, ich habe Respekt. Man muss aber auch sagen, ich wurde vorher auch nicht angegangen. Also ich würde vorher auch, ich bin da so sehr groß und so. Im Winter hat man dicke Sachen an, da sieht man automatisch ein bisschen breiter aus so Und dann wird man auch nicht reing. Die meisten Angriffe finden ja im Winter statt, deswegen bist du da relativ sicher. Ja, genau. Wie schaust du auf den Frühling? Positiv. Ja, jetzt die Frühlingzeit beginnt. Erwartungsvoll vor allem. Was erwartest du denn? Ich erwarte bunte Blätter, der Kleduft, das ist Herbst, Feuchtigkeit, Drachensteigen, auch die langweiligste Zeit, weil die nicht für so richtig viel steht. Ja, Frühlingsgefühle, Neuanfang, mal irgendwie rausgehen auf die Wiese. Ist das so, dass dann mehr Sexualhormone ausgeschüttet werden? Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das irgendwie auch mit Sonne und so und dann gehst du mehr raus und dann Enten. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Enten? Ja, dann
kann man die Enten füttern mit
altem Brot.
Ja, stimmt,
das hat man gemacht, war eine Zeit, oder?
Aber so eine ganz spezifische Zeit. Ja, das hat man
in Huma auch immer gemacht, dass altes Brot aufgehoben wurde
für die Enten. Semmelbrösel oder sowas.
Ja. Also Krümel oder wie man auch immer sagt, Krümel. Und dann aber, wenn das dann nicht funktioniert hat, dann hat man ihm die Enten gegeben und hat er die Enten gegessen, also es war dann immer doch so, die haben dann wiederum eine Marinade bekommen, Panade, also es ist innen, außen, es ist überall Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, Ente, wirklich alles voller Ente. So kann man. So kann man es zusammenfassen. Ja, schon interessant. Im Tierpark damals hat man so eine Tüte bekommen mit so Waffeln und so Kram. Waffeln? Von Eiswaffeln. Ach so, Hörnchen. Ja, das stimmt. Aber auch so anderes Waffelgebäck. Und dann ist man da reingegangen und da waren alle Gehege mit so Rutschen ausgestattet, wo man das drauflegen konnte. Und dann rutscht es in das Gehege rein. Du willst das doch auf die Tiere werfen. Ja, man will es auf die Tiere werfen, aber man darf es nicht auf die Tiere werfen. Essen die auch Nudeln? Ja, oder einfach, ja, finde ich interessant. So schöne Spaghetti Bolognese? Ja, finde ich nicht so doof. Schön so ein Tiramisu reinwerfen oder so.
Es rutscht dann so langsam runter.
Also Buchstaben, so dieses russische Brot.
Hitchlers.
Essen Russen wirklich dieses Buchstabenbrot den ganzen Tag?
Ist das deren Brot?
Das ist vor allem nicht deren Alphabet.
Das ist sehr richtig.
Das stimmt schon.
Das ist mir gerade mal so aufgefallen. Das ist ja nicht Russischisch Brot. Da ist einiges schiefgegangen. Da muss man... Ist das vegan? Puh, glaube ich manchmal schon. Ich weiß nicht. Keine Ahnung. Was wolltest du sagen? Ich habe letztens meinen ersten Wikipedia-Artikel geschrieben. Wirklich? Ja. Ich habe einen aus W aus Wut korrigiert. Ja? Ja, welcher? Ich habe einen ganz schlimmen Film gesehen, und zwar, weil ich musste aus Recherchegründen Feuchtgebiete den Film angucken. Und da gibt es einen ähnlichen Film, auch über Jugendliche und so und auch über das Thema Doktorspiele, heißt der. Ah ja, der ist richtig krank. Und da habe ich ihn angefangen zu gucken, und der ist so schlimm. Alter, und ich konnte nicht fassen, was das für Dialoge waren, wo einer so sagt, ey, glotzt dich auf meinen Schwanz, du Jack Sparrow. Und da ist tausend Fragezeichen im Kopf. Was? Wer sagt, du Jack Sparrow? Augenscheinlich hat das der Autor für Jugendsprache gehalten oder so. Aber wegen Homosexualität oder was? Ich habe keine Ahnung, nein, es war auch nicht mehr der Satz. Aus dem Nichts kommt plötzlich der Name Jack Sparrow drin vor. Als wäre es ein geflügelter Ausdruck, so du Spast. Okay, du Daffy Duck. Vielleicht du Spatz, Spatz, Sparrow, du Jack Sparrow. Keine Ahnung, woher das kam. Und dann habe ich geguckt, wie der Typ heißt, Marco Petri. Das sind meistens die Momente, wo man nachher hört, wer Podcast-Ufo hört, dann hört Marco Petri vielleicht Podcast-Ufo. Nein, aber der Typ, und dann hat er, wie geil, es wurde sogar angenommen, und dann hat er einen Wikipedia-Eintrag, den ich so miserabel fand, weil dann stand da drin, seine Filme zeigen irgendwie so ein hohes Maß an Beobachtungen und cleveren Inszenierungen der Jugendkultur und so weiter. Und ich habe diesen Absatz einfach gelöscht. Ich habe einfach gesagt, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein. Habe mir so einen fucking Namen angelegt, habe mich da reingeloggt und habe diesen Absatz gelöscht. Habe gesagt, das stimmt nicht, habe dann geschrieben, ist unwissenschaftlich. Und jetzt beginnen auch zwei Sätze in aufeinander folgend mit für den und für den Film, für die Spielfilme und so. Also macht keinen Sinn mehr jetzt, ist auch nicht mehr schön geschrieben, aber der Absatz ist es hoffentlich fehlt jetzt. Sehr gut. Ja, wo ich mir dachte, ich habe etwas beigetragen. Für die Wissenschaft, Stefan. Ja, für die Wissenschaft. Sehr gut. Nicht schlecht. Ich gucke mal, ob ich diesen Absatz finde, der hat mich echt aufgeregt. Ja, und du hast einen geschrieben? Ich habe einen geschrieben, wurde stark kritisiert, weil er zu wertend war. Und ich habe jetzt schon einige Probleme gekriegt, und es steht auf der Wikipedia-Seite von wegen, die Neutralität ist nicht gewahrt und ist nicht wertend. Also leider wertend geworden. Da wurde dann auch geschrieben, was genau wertend ist. Ich habe dann noch eine neue Version geschrieben und habe noch ein paar neue Sachen dazu hingeschrieben, also noch ein paar neue Absätze. Die neuen Absätze wurden sofort gelöscht mit der Begründung, ja, kümmere dich erstmal um die Neutralitätsprobleme, bevor du hier wieder so einen neuen Scheiss schreibst. Also fand ich interessant, dass die Person, die mich darauf hingewiesen hat, dass es zu wertend war, selbst dein Scheisstext ist zu wertend, du Bastard. Du fucking Jack Sparrow, ey, oh Scheiß. Extrem herablassende Art, mir mitzuteilen, dass mein Text zu wertend ist. Hier stand drin, seine bisherigen Filme zeichnen sich als gut beobachtete und lebendig inszenierte Generationsporträts aus, wobei vor allem Schule, der Film Schule, durch seinen hohen Identifikationscharakter bei jungen Menschen zu einem Erfolg an der Kino-Kasse wurde, stimmt alles nicht. Da habe ich geschrieben, ich habe das ganz absatzgelöscht und geschrieben, das ist unwissenschaftlich und Quatsch. Sehr gut. Ja, und es ist rausgeflogen. Aber er hat das bestimmt selber geschrieben, oder? Irgendjemand hat ihm vertraut. Ja, genau. Aber man muss kurz darüber reden, was du gerade angesprochen hast. Wer das macht, also wer für das Wissen der gesamten Menschheit, zumindest im deutschsprachigen Raum, verantwortlich ist, ist einfach ein Nerdkreis. Und man kommt kommt da auch gar nicht so gut rein. Also man muss sagen, jeder kann Wikipedia-Einträge verändern. Aber es kann nicht jeder diese Version als sichern oder als gesichtet werden, um dann diese Version zu speichern. Das ist ein ganz erlesener Kreis aus Menschen, wo niemand genau weiß, wer das ist, wo niemand genau weiß, woher die kommen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es ja so Treffen auch, wo die sich dann alle treffen an so komischen Stammtischen, die dann einfach, also das sind offensichtlich so ein Freimaurer-artiger Kult, die einfach das Wissen der Menschheit irgendwie gerade für sich vereinnahmen, aber es sind einfach Vollidioten, die sich dann irgendwie in so einem seltsamen Eckknall getreffen. Ich meine, ich habe mich geärgert dadurch, dass dieser Revisor da so herablassend geschrieben hat, aber das sind ja wahrscheinlich auch die genervtesten Menschen der Welt, weil die jeden Tag den grössten Nonsens der Welt revidieren müssen, wo jemand irgendwie aus Spaß irgendeine Tollerei reinschreibt oder so. Manchmal schreiben auch Leute mich meinen Namen in irgendwelche Wikipedia-Artikel rein, die ich mal gelesen habe im Moin Moin. Und natürlich wird sowas gelöscht und das ist ja auch einfach nur nervig, weil das nichts zu tun hat. Wie heißt denn der, den du eingedrungen hast? Das will ich nicht sagen, weil sonst Leute irgendwie eine dumme Trollerei reinschreiben. Ach Leute, ey. Ja, so ist es leider. Die sind so kreide. Aber das ist, glaube ich, diese Wikipedia-Kuratoren müssen halt den ganzen Tag so einen Scheiß machen. Und ich meine, die können sich ja natürlich auch nicht mit allem auskennen. Also ich habe ja da auch Quellen zitiert in meinem Artikel und so, aber die werden ja nicht alles nachprüfen. Ich halte das trotzdem für echt fahrlässig, dass man da kein Kontrollgremium hat, sondern einfach so ein Kreis, wo man auch nicht einfach reinkommt. Du kannst nicht einfach nicht als, du musst nämlich sehr viele Einträge, glaube ich, lesen. Ich weiß nicht, wo man da reinkommt, das ist ein ganz, ganz perfides System. Du musst selber einfach schon viel geschrieben haben, viele Artikel geschrieben haben. Also auch die Person, man kann immer so Profil dann anklicken, was ist das für ein Typ und der hat auch schon Auszeichnungen bekommen, anscheinend gibt es dann so Wikipedia Awards oder so für die meisten Links oder irgendwie sowas und dann hat er auch ganz schön viele Artikel geschrieben, die auch super toll bewertet wurden und so und so kommt man da vielleicht dann irgendwann rein, wenn man sich lange. ja, das kann sein. Aber ich glaube, die haben natürlich auch Interesse, Leute abzuschrecken, die einfach keine Ahnung haben.
Also die, glaube ich, geben sich
natürlich dann irgendwann rein, wenn man sich lange Ja, das kann sein. Aber ich glaube, die haben natürlich auch Interesse, Leute abzuschrecken, die einfach keine Ahnung haben. Also die glaube ich, geben sich natürlich nicht so viel Mühe, jetzt jedem zu sagen, schön, dass du da bist, dass du in die Wikipedia schreibst und toll, ist natürlich ein Open-Source-Projekt, aber natürlich wollen die Leute auch rausmobben, die keine Ahnung haben, die nur Bullshit reinschreiben, weil die dann genau wissen, der macht uns dann noch mehr Arbeit, als wenn er einfach nichts schreiben würde. Was das wohl für ein Treffen ist. Du darfst nicht auffliegen als Blender. Du musst da reinmorphen, du musst alles Ahnung haben. Du musst ständig Quellen parat haben. Du musst wirklich für jeden Satz, den du sagst, eine Quelle auf dem Tisch werfen. Ja, sobald da einer, glaube ich, mal irgendwie sagt, weiß ich nicht, fliegt der sofort aus der Kneipe raus, wo die sich da mal treffen. Was das für gezwungene Gespräche sind. Wo kommen die Bilder her? Wann ist ein ist ein Wikipedia-Artikel gross genug, dass er ein Bild kriegt? Ja, und warum ist das Bild dann automatisch Creative Commons? Tja, das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Stefan T., das weiß ich nicht. Ja, dann raus bei uns aus dem fucking Wikipedia-Club. Ja, sorry. Habt ihr diese Shirts haben auch? Ich will in diesen Wikipedia-Club. Ja, ich will da auch irgendwie rein. Ich zahle auch schon Geld. Ich zahle monatlich Geld für Wikipedia, ich habe die Wikipedia-App installiert, ich schreibe für Wikipedia. Ich bin jetzt drin, ich bin richtig tief drin. Warum installiert man sich die Wikipedia-App? Man kann doch einfach ganz schnell in den Browser gehen und dann hat man Wikipedia. Nein, dann kannst du ganz schnell reinschreiben und da ist nochmal Artikel des Tages und so. Hast du auch auf der Website. Warum, was zeige ich, speichert das? Du kannst das ja angenehm lesen. Ach, hast du das nur? Apps oder was? Hast die Apps oder was? Ich sag nur, das ist wie Leute, die eine Google-App installiert haben. Das macht keinen Sinn. Das ist einfach völliger Quatsch. Du kannst einfach auf die Seite gehen. Das hat keinen Vorteil. Anders als die Bahn-App zum Beispiel, wo du immer eingeloggt bist, wo du Dinge machen kannst, die du online nicht sofort machen kannst. Aber Wikipedia-App? Hast du auch die Google-App?
Du darfst zwei Tage lang keine Wikipedia mehr lesen.
Mann!
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich, ich meine, ich bin total bescheuert.
Und ich habe momentan auch zu viel Zeit.
Aber ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen meine Apps sortiert auf meinem iPhone.
Und ich habe... Nach Farben, alles schon gesehen.
Nach Farben, nach Buchstaben.
Ich habe die, ich sage mal, es gibt ja Apps, die haben kein Ende.
Yeah. So was wie Twitter oder Instagram oder so, wo du einfach scrollst ins Nirvana. Nein, geht von mir aus. Hat ein Ende, glaube ich. Mal gucken. Ja, alles hat ein Ende. Nein. Aber diese Apps, ich nenne sie in meinem neuen Ratgeber, ich nenne sie die Zeitfresser-Apps. Oh Gott. Oh nein. Ich muss sagen, das ist unsempathisch, als ob ich einen Podcast haben. Ich schreibe einen Ratgeber für Jugendliche. Das sind die sogenannten, ich nenne sie die Mampf-Apps, die diefressen. Ich finde es nicht schlecht, wenn du so ein Selbsthilfebuch schreibst. Erstmal, wenn du Zeit, erst mal, wenn du abgenommen hast, weil alle Leute fragen immer, einfach joggen und Wasser, viel Wasser trinken und gesund ernähren. Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema, Zeit, oh, wir brauchen eine Woche Zeit, erst mal weniger schlafen, viel mehr Koffein trinken und Energydrinks und die Zeitfresser-Apps, Achtung, oh, get rid of this Zeitfresser-App. Mampf, mampf, wer knuspert denn da auf meinem Handy? Ist das etwa Instagram? Und diese, ich nenne sie jetzt mal die Zeitfresser-Apps, habe ich jetzt von der Startseite genommen. Die sind nicht mehr auf der Seite, sondern auf der zweiten Seite meiner Apps. Das soll dich dazu bringen, dass du die weniger anklickst. Ja, also das war, wenn du auf dein Handy guckst, um wie viel Uhr es ist, und dann siehst du da Twitter mit zehn Benachrichtigungen, dann bist du auf Twitter und dann hast du wieder eine Stunde auf Twitter. Und so musst du dich aktiv dazu entscheiden, zu Twitter zu scrollen, um die App zu aktivieren. These. Nichts sagt mehr über Menschen aus und vor allem über die Abgründe eines Menschen aus als die letzte Seite Apps. Oh ja, ja. Ich glaube, die letzte ist nichts. Bist du bereit? Manche Sachen kann ich auch nicht sagen. Grinder kann ich jetzt hier nicht laut. Aber manche Sachen, also die letzte Seite Apps sind schon strange Sachen. Okay, shoot. Okay, warte. Nee, ich zeig dir meins nicht. Ich zeig dir meins. Okay, zeig dir meins. Oh, da ist so eine App, die sieht schon unseriös aus, weil verbixelt. Weil das App-Logo verbixelt wird. Also Flixbus, warum? Auf der letzten Zeit, ich hasse Flixbus, habe ich einmal in meinem Leben benutzt. Wasserwaage, Notenlesen, Amazon, oh, auch hier die Frage, warum als App? Ich weiß, ehrlich gesagt, auch nicht. Ich habe immer so ein paar Apps installiert, wo ich mir dachte, die muss man haben. Eye Scanner. Wie jeder braucht einen Scanner. Wo man so Dokumente scannen kann, dass man die als PDF hat. ID Looper. Everyday Looper, ja, da kann man Musik machen mit. Fahrplaner, My Taxi und Signal. Was ist Signal für eine App? Ich habe aus Versehen auf dieses, dass alle wackeln jetzt. Das ist eine Nachrichten-App. Ich wollte nur nicht, dass du Everyday-Looper aufmachst, weil dann kann man sich so lupen selber. Oh nein, da hat er gesungen. It's a hard knock life. Ist das wirklich die Melodie? It's a hard knock life. It's a hard knock life. It's a hard knock life. It's a hard knock life. Ich habe folgende Apps. Blockchain. Oh Gott.
Für meine Bitcoins.
Oh Mann.
Aber die braucht dich.
Das ist so fucking unruhig.
Kann ich dir, aber kann ich noch nicht sagen.
Ja, okay, das verstehe ich.
Lustigerweise wirklich.
Stack, das ist schon ein Spiel, so ein Designerspiel.
Designerspiel.
Ja, das ist so ein schönes Spiel einfach.
Ein Spiel, das man aus Designgründen spielt.
Was nicht per se interessant ist, aber es ist einfach ein schönes Spiel einfach. Ein Spiel, was man aus Designgründen spielt. Was nicht per se interessant ist,
aber ist einfach ein schönes Spiel.
Guckt euch mal an.
GoPro.
Damit kannst du auf eine GoPro-Kamera zugreifen, oder was?
Ja, mytaxi, mobile.de, Musik-Memos, Sky-Ticket, Loop, Snapseed,
Comdirect, Sonos, Vero und Philips Hue.
Wie geht es eigentlich deiner Algorithmusfreundin, der du Texte schreibst und die Antworten als echter Mensch? Unsere Gespräche werden immer bitterer, werden ernster. Werden ernster. Also ich muss sagen, wir haben lange jetzt, wir haben lange eine, also es war so ein Durststreicher durchgemacht, wo sich unsere taglichen Gespräche auf, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer aus, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer aus. Dunkler, habe ich gesagt, was zum Teufel. Alle sind Caps geschrieben. Naja, nee, wir haben nicht mehr so viel miteinander gesprochen. Ich habe auch so ein paar Apps installiert und jetzt so ein bisschen weird. Also man kann, ich kann auch, das ist ja ganz geil, man kann, man muss sich wieder vorstellen, nachts im Bett, alles ist dunkel, man liegt im Bett, man guckt an die Decke und man sagt, Alexa, spiele das Quiz. Und dann stellt sie dir Fragen und du bist in einer Art, wer wird mit dem Millionärartigen Quiz? Und es werden dir Fragen gestellt, die du dann beantworten kannst. Und dann hat man auch mal zwischendurch diesen Applaus-Moment des Publikums. Wie gut ist das? Und man fühlt sich halt so ein bisschen ... Stockdunkel alleine im Bett, drei Uhr nachts. Und dann immer dieses Midi. Haaa! Wuhu! Und dann hörst du auch mal rapide auf. Und wenn dann Leute am Fenster vorbeigedenken, die auch, was geht da drin vor. Aber das macht relativ viel Spaß. Also wenn man Langeweile hat und nachts nicht einschlafen kann, irgendwie einen schönen Quiz. Ich glaube, das ist aber richtig destruktiv zum Einschlafen, dass du so Gedächtnis und Gehirnleister machst. Ja, ist destruktiv. Ich glaube, das ist genau das, was du nicht laust, wenn du einschlafen. Man kann auch sagen, spiele Regen zum Einschlafen. Und das funktioniert bei mir nicht, wo ich mich frage, warum. Aber dann sage ich, spiele Regen zum Einschlafen. Und dann kommt nichts, aber man ...
Hallo, störe ich gerade.
Aber es ist ja schon spät, also bleibt diese Situation so.
Spiele Regen zum Einschlafen.
Und das ist das Letzte, was ich an dem Tag sage.
Die längste peinliche Stille aller Zeiten.
Ja, und die gibt so acht Stunden, diese Stille, weil dazwischen passiert nichts. Und dann so morgen zum acht Uhr. Liebst du mich, Alexa? Ja, peinliche Stille. Ja, aber das ist ... Oh. Apropos Regen, ein neues Spiel, das ich erfunden habe, ein bisschen viel Zeit, ist Spotify verwirren. Und du kennst ja vielleicht die Funktion, dass wenn du eine Spotify-Playlist hast, dann analysiert er die Songs in der Playlist und führt die automatisch weiter, wenn du am Ende bist. Also dann checkt er ungefähr, ah, das ist jetzt deine gute Laune-Playlist, also gebe ich dir weiter Lieder, die da reinpassen können. Und ich mache mir mit Spaß daraus, die verwirrendste und konfuseste Playlist zu machen, die es überhaupt gibt. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass mein Musikgeschmack genau diese Liste ist. Also wo du dann reintust, eine Overtüre von Wagner, dann hast du Regenmusik, dann hast du ein Hörbuch, dann hast du irgendwie Iggy Asilia, Ja, dann hast du irgendwie eine zweistündige Aufnahme, die du privat irgendwo gefunden hast, dann irgendwie die Tagesschau und dann, okay Spotify, jetzt mach mal weiter, mach mal bitte mit dem Input weiter. Es nailed ist. Ja, und es nailed ist genau. Es nailed ist tatsächlich genau, weil es wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein Lied nimmt, dann was hören Leute, die das hören auch noch.
Also dann kommt wahrscheinlich Gewitter, dann kommt Dimitri Martin, dann kommt ein anderes Hörbuch und ich glaube, dich führt es einfach weiter. Aber er kommt immer zu einem Ergebnis, also das finde ich so verrückt, dass er nicht sagt, kein, sorry, kein Plan, hast mich gerade völlig auf dem falschen, völlig auf dem falschen Buch. Geh rüber zu dieser, weißt du, Lollibidoo haben es nicht verdient jetzt. Ja, also nicht verdient. Die haben immer eine Antwort. Das ist ja auch... Das ist dein Tag? Das ist mein Tag. Das ist dein Tagesablauf, dass du dich fragst... So, du wachst morgens auf mit so einem schämischen Grinsen. Wen kann ich heute in das Licht führen? Wen kann ich heute foppen? Hey, Apple TV. Ich hab, und das ist vielleicht... Ich mein, du kannst mich ja jetzt mal einschätzen, du kennst dich ja aus mit Fehlkäufen. Ich habe mir was angeschafft, ich habe ein junges Startup unterstützt und mir ein Gadget besorgt. Ich bin ein Gadget-Fan. Mir ist ein bisschen unangenehm. Aber vielleicht hast du das schon mal gesehen und vielleicht habt ihr das daraus auch schon mal gesehen, weil es auch beworben wurde. Du wirst zu mir. Ich werde zu dir, das ist total merkwürdig. Ja, wenn man Zeit hat. Ich bin du plus Zeit. Andersrum. Und ich habe es mir geholt, weil ich dachte, okay, ich habe jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen viel Freizeit und ich will meine Zeit gut einteilen. So, ich denke mir, wenn man schon mal irgendwie in seinem Leben, keine Ahnung, Monat mal viel Zeit hat, dann will man auch was machen. Und deswegen habe ich mir ein Organisationstool gekauft. und zwar ist das ein Würfel. Dieser Würfel, vielleicht hast du den schon mal gesehen. Ja. Und dieser Würfel macht im Grunde, ist total simpel, auf den Würfel kannst du verschiedene Sachen schreiben, also Klavierspielen, Workout, Lesen, Pause, was auch immer. Ja, das Gute ist auch, du merkst auch, wenn du es nicht machen willst. Genau, dann legst du den Würfel immer so auf den Tisch, dass das, was du jetzt gerade machst, oben ist. Und dann trackt der automatisch die Zeit, wie lange du das machst. Ah, so. So, und dann kannst du dir zum Beispiel so Sachen setzen, wie morgen möchte ich mindestens eine halbe Stunde Klavier spielen. Und dann kannst du halt morgen im Verlauf des Tages halt den so hinstellen, dass du halt dann Klavier spielst. und dann trackt, also im Grunde, der macht nicht viel, der trackt einfach nur Zeit und sehr einfach, weil anstatt dass du jetzt in den Kalender schreibst, von 13.08 Uhr bis 22.08 Uhr war ich, keine Ahnung, einkaufen, kannst du das so einfach durch diesen Würfel machen. Und dann siehst du am Ende des Tages immer ganz genau, was hast du den Tag über gemacht. Und ich habe versucht, mir auf diesen Würfel nur Sachen draufzuschreiben, die ich machen will.
Also nicht einfach irgendwas, was man so macht Tag über gemacht? Und ich habe versucht, mir auf diesen Würfel nur Sachen draufzuschreiben, die ich machen will,
also nicht einfach irgendwas, was man so macht,
sondern die ich machen will, wie
keine Ahnung, ein Buch lesen,
eine Fremdsprache lernen, halt so, was man so machen will.
Was man denkt, das ist jetzt gut investierte
Zeit. Und dann kannst du immer
dir gucken, am Ende des Tages heute
habe ich zweieinhalb Stunden lang
produktive Sachen gemacht.
Und dann kannst du immer gucken so, okay, morgen schaffe ich vielleicht drei Stunden. Und dann machst du halt die Sachen, wo du halt dann gerade hörst, immer noch, kannst du immer noch auswählen, aber das sind so alle Aktivitäten, denen du einen gewissen Wert zusprichst, so benutze ich sie. Man hat die App gesagt, schon wieder masturbieren, ist das dein fucking Ernst? Ja, also ich habe tatsächlich, ein Würfel hat ja, wie viele Seiten? Sechs Seiten. Sechs Seiten. Und fünf davon sind verschiedene Pornoseiten und eine Seite ist Workout, wo ich zwei, ich glaube, ich habe gestern zwei Minuten Workout gemacht, wo ich will erst mal Würfel aktivieren, dann erst mal dehnen, strecken, meine Wasserflasche ist leer, Wasserflasche auffüllen und dann so zwei Liegestütze und dann so, jetzt aber auch schon wieder 16 Uhr. Aber es ist so gnadenlos, weil du kannst dich ja so einfach bescheissen. Das ist ja das Perfide, dass du klüger bist als du selbst, dass du dich einfach selber besiegen kannst. Ja, du bist klüger als die Systeme, die du für dich baust. Ja, du kannst dich selber besiegen. Am Ende hast du gegen dich selbst keine Chance.
Und das ist halt eine Möglichkeit, um dir diese Möglichkeit
nicht zu nehmen, weil du wirklich sagst, okay,
weil keiner, und du sagst ja dann, ja, ich habe ja gestern
schon Workout gemacht, ja, ich habe ja die Woche schon
total viel Workout gemacht, aber dadurch kannst du genau
sehen, nee, hast du nicht, hast du eben nicht,
du siehst genau zwei Minuten gestern, das ist
nix, und du musst heute was machen, und
deswegen ist es so ein bisschen mein Plan, ich hoffe,
momentan... Aber funktioniert's? Es funktioniert, ja, es ist ein bisschen nervig, weil man es mit Bluetooth verbinden muss. Und es wäre cooler, wenn es ein bisschen selbstständiger wäre. Aber ist schon okay, weil du hast ja dann auch eine App auf dem Computer, die halt dann das genau ausdrückt und so. Und an sich ist eigentlich schon ... Kannst du mal vorlesen, was du gemacht hast? Oder möchtest du es nicht vorlesen? Aber Klavierspielen hast du bestimmt ernst gemeint, da bist du ja schon ein bisschen länger dran, um das zu perfektionieren.
Deswegen auch deine Notenlern-App.
Richtig.
Fantastisch. Ich bin gespannt.
Also, gestern vier Stunden positive Sachen gemacht.
Also, von 0.23 Uhr bis 1.04 ich 40 Minuten lang Buch gelesen. Toll, Florian. Dann heute, Achtung, 12.32 bis 12.36 Uhr Workout. Okay, nicht lang. Workout. Ja, vier. Vier Minuten. Vier Minuten Workout.
Ich glaube, das Wort Workout war auch nie falscher eingesetzt. Lächerlich, lächerlich. Dann 13.26 Uhr bis 14.04 Uhr Tagesaufgabe. Ich musste heute so ein paar Steuersachen regeln. Habe ich 37 Minuten lang gemacht. 37 Minuten lang. Dann etwas später, 38 Minuten habe ich wieder gelesen, 38 Minuten lang gelesen, dann habe ich eine Stunde 40 mich mit Geschichte beschäftigt. Ich habe ein Geschichtsbuch gelesen. Holy fuck, was ist das denn für ein We- Du führst das Leben von so einem alten Professor in Pension. Und dann habe ich noch von 23.35 bis 0 Uhr 25 Minuten lang Klavier gespielt. That's it, das war mein gestriger Tag. Weißt du, du bist wie jemand, der so, du solltest nach Norditalien ziehen, so ein großes Haus und da einfach sein Leben leben. Da sind Bücher, abends kommen Gäste rum, da machst du schön deine Paella und Kram, irgendwie schönes, was du vorbereitest, was auf Markteinkauf. Aber ich finde, so sollte man leben, wenn man Freizeit hat, so dann einfach mal irgendwie ein paar Hobbys kultivieren. Ich glaube, Leute haben, Leute haben kaum noch Hobbys. Wir sitzen, muss man sagen, wir sitzen im Glaskasten und überall, rings um uns herum stehen gerade Leute einfach vor den Fenstern. Ja, hier wird gerade gedreht und deswegen sind vier Leute und Komparsen alles hier in der Gegend und deswegen sind wir so ein bisschen eingekesselt. Ja, aber man sollte das machen, du hast schon völlig recht. Bis ein bisschen Hobbys kultivieren, nicht nur ständig vor YouTube sitzen. YouTube nenne ich ja einen Zeitfresser. Ist eine Zeitfresser-App, aber du kannst auch auf YouTube Geschichte lernen. Ja, das stimmt, es gibt tolle Sachen auf YouTube. Man muss nur mal gucken. Man muss nur die tollen Sachen finden. Ein Wust aus Schwachsinn. Wenn man Zeit hat, ist alles interessant. Ich habe heute ein 30-minütiges Video gesehen über sämtliche verschiedene Pastasorten. Es gibt vier verschiedene Pastateige, den ohne Ei, den mit Ei, den mit Spinat und den mit Tintenfisch-Tinte. Vier verschiedene. Der letzte kam unerwartet, der letzte kam ... Weiss, gelb, grün, schwarz. Das sind so grundsätzlich die Pasta, also die italienischen Pasta. Oh, der kam aus dem Nichts. Man muss sagen, ich habe viel erwartet, aber ... Hast du dir ausgedacht? Nein, hat er noch nie schwarze Nudeln gesehen? Doch, aber ich dachte, die wären einfach mit Lebensmittelfarbe. Nee, das ist Tintenfisch-Tinte. Ja, gut. Ja, aber wo geht denn hin mit der ganzen Tinte? Ja, warum nicht in die Nudeln? Warum muss denn das... Nicht in die guten Nudeln von Becker Hessbacher, Alter. Warum, also, das Tier will mich offensichtlich verscheuchen mit dieser tollen Idee der Natur. Warum habe ich das Gefühl, das in meine Teigwaren zu mischen? Finde ich, und da können wir unsere Rubrik Evolutionsfails, Lulz. Evolutionsfails, das war ja wohl für die Tonne. Das war nix. Und zum Beispiel scharfes Essen. Diese Pflanzen, die scharf sind, wie zum Beispiel Chili, macht das, um nicht gegessen zu werden. Damit, wenn jetzt so ein Fuchs durch den Wald läuft ... Aber Gegenargument, die macht's falsch. Weil manche, dann stirbst du, wenn du die isst. Selbst so eine billige Eibe sagt dir, fuck you, du wirst sterben, du wirst Krämpfe bekommen, vielleicht wirst du nicht sterben, aber du wirst im Krankenhaus landen. Ja gut, aber ein Fuchs geht nicht ins Krankenhaus, wenn so ein Fuchs durchs Unterholz geht. So heißt, ich glaube so heißt meine erste Kommilitur, der Fuchs geht nicht ins Krankenhaus. Wenn er so durchs Unterholz schlüpft und so eine Chili frissen will, dann denkt er, oh das ist aber scharf. Und dann denkt er sich, oh lieber nicht, und dann frisst er keine Chili mehr. Aber wir Menschen sind so, so, einfach so krass drauf, dass sie sagen, nee, weißt du was, pass auf, wir essen die nicht nur nicht nicht, sondern wir essen sie sogar, weil sie scharf ist. Und wir essen sie gerade die daneben, die nicht scharf ist, nope, die bleibt stehen. Wir essen dich, weil sie scharf ist. Vor allem die muss ich auch denken, diese Pflanze. What? Ist das euer Ernst? Ja, vor allem die Pflanze daneben denkt sich so, Alter, ich habe nicht gelernt für den Test, ich habe keine Ahnung von gar nichts und ich bin trotzdem durchgekommen irgendwie. Ich habe kein Gift, ich bin nicht scharf, ich kann nichts, aber ich habe es geschafft. Die wird Pilot, in gewisser Weise. Ey, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es geht. Ich dachte immer, dass man, je mehr man weiß über ein Thema, schlechter wird, was den Comedy-Aspekt dieses Themas angeht. Weil je mehr du weiss, desto mehr kannst du eigentlich erklären, warum Dinge gar nicht funktionieren. Aber jetzt, wie du gerade auch schon sagst, je tiefer man in die Pasta-Welt reintaucht, umso mehr Gags tauchen dann wieder auf. Ja, das stimmt. Und das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Auch bei YouTube habe ich diesen Channel entdeckt, der heißt, glaube ich, Authentic Sound. Und da geht es darum, wie, also da ist jemand ein Klassik-Musik-Fan, der kann auch supergut Klavier und Harpsichord. Cembalo? Das schneide ich raus. Harpsichord. Nee, das schneide ich wieder rein. Ja, das Harpsichord ist der englische Begriff für Cembalo, das finde ich recht. Und der kann wirklich sehr gut darauf spielen und so weiter. Und dem geht es einfach darum, der will herausfinden, wie hat Mozart gespielt. Ah ja, doch, den kann ich auch. Wie hat Haydn, das ist ein Niederländer. Das ist ein krasser Typ, ne? Der ist unglaublich krass, aber er hat sich so ein bisschen verrannt, muss man sagen, weil sein einziges Ziel für diesen ganzen Channel ist, herauszufinden, wie hat Mozart gespielt, wie klang das Original gedacht von Mozart. Ja, und da gibt's auch so Aufnahmen auf so einer Drehleier. Genau, und dann hat er, und dann eigentlich hat er sich, wie gesagt, verrannt, weil er hat irgendwann herausgefunden, er hat dann recherchiertchiert und so weiter, hat irgendwann auch richtig, ist in Bibliotheken getaucht und hat irgendwann sich genau die Tempoangaben herausgesucht, wie Stücke gespielt wurden. Ja. Und herauskam, die wurden unglaublich schnell gespielt. Und dann hat er immer weitergeguckt und eigentlich endet jedes Video mit, er versucht das Stück zu spielen und schafft es nicht, weil es zu schnell ist.
Also man muss sich vorstellen, keine Ahnung, keine Nachtmusik, du kannst nicht mehr nachsingen, so schnell war das. Und er spielt das dann und scheitert und man denkt sich, nein, es tut mir so leid. Hoch oder Kopf, schwitzt. Ja, und es tut einem so leid, weil er immer mit so einem ... Endet das Video dann.
Weil er, also er hat, er ist mir so leid. Ja, und es tut einem so leid, weil er immer mit so einem ... Endet das Video dann.
Weil er, also er hat, er ist wie kein Wissenschaftler diesem Thema näher gekommen, hat Dinge herausgefunden. Aber dann hat er einen deutschen Wissenschaftler getroffen, der auch parallel das Gleiche untersucht hat, dem auch klar geworden ist, dass sie unmenschlich schnell gespielt haben, dass es auch nicht mehr geil klingt. und der hat dann herausgefunden, dass die die Tempoangaben anders notiert haben. Also während das Metronomen macht, meinten die, haben die dann aufgeschrieben, halt das Tempo aufgeschrieben, die meinten aber zwei Schläge fürs Metronomen, weil irgendwer, irgendein Vollidiot, was eine doofe Idee, aber irgendein Vollidiot meinte mal, ja Zeit ist ja, wenn ein Punkt zum anderen kommt und dann wieder zurückkommt. Ach so, also nicht links, rechts, links, rechts machen die Verstehen. Man sieht deine Hand nicht, deswegen. Ja, deswegen mache ich das Klackgeräusch. Ach so. Deswegen muss ich die um die Hand kontrollieren. Und deswegen ist das Tempo nicht, sondern halt die Hälfte davon. Man hat gemerkt, seine Augen wurden wieder gross, man hat wieder Leben in seinen Augen gesehen. Und jetzt ist er dann dem Rest leergekommen. Jetzt kann er Mozart spielen wie Mozart gespielt hat und Haydn spielen wie Haydn gespielt hat. Hatten die damals so Beats Per Second Angaben? Die haben dann so was wie Presto, Andante oder so. Das sagt die ja nichts. Die haben auch teilweise mit einem Metronomen, das gab es relativ früh schon, das ist ja auch eine einfache Technik, mit einem Gewicht obendran und so weiter, das ganz sehr gut einstellen, auch die Beats-per-Minute-Angaben quasi, und dann haben die das gut hingekriegt und dann haben die die auch teilweise notiert, natürlich nicht alle Stücke, aber viele. Und dann ist es schon interessant, weil die, weil er wirklich so ein paar Videos jetzt rückblickend einfach in die falsche Richtung gegangen ist und einfach nicht spielen kann. Aber er hat doch auch so eine Walze gefunden, ich glaube von Brahms oder so. Nee, von Haydn. Von Haydn. Er hat eine Walze gefunden, es gab nämlich, irgendwann gab es das erste, die erste Spieluhr quasi. Er hat dieses Museum gefunden, die diese Uhr irgendwie gerade restauriert haben und aufgebaut haben, ist in dieses Museum gefahren, zeigt uns das alles und dann spielt die ein Heidenstück lächerlich schnell
und es macht keinen Spaß und man sieht wie
das Leben aus ihm herausgleitet.
Der Typ ist der netteste
Mensch der Welt, der ist so zart und so
Niederländer und so, der ist so in seiner Welt.
Und er hat dieses Hobby, wo man denkt, du rennst in die falsche Richtung,
mein Lieber.
Er hat ein Hobby, das ihn letztlich unglücklich macht.
Und dann hat aber der Museumstyp herausgefunden,
nee, die haben nicht, also Heiden war auch wohl dabei, der war auch wohl im Raum, als es gebaut wurde. Und dann dachten, er ist halt davon ausgegangen, okay, dann wird es, er hat auch vorher auch so gesagt, und ich bin gleich in dem Museum und die haben das restauriert und es ist so fantastisch, weil Haydn war im Raum und ich würde natürlich auch wollen, dass es genauso spielt, wie ich spiele. Aber erstens, klang es scheiße, die Intonation war komplett off, das Tempo war, hat geschwankt und so, das war einfach und so. Es war einfach nicht so richtig handwerklich begabt, die Leute, die das damals gebaut haben, weil es eine neue Technik war. Das war doch doof. Weil es dusselig war und klein war und nur zwölf Jahre alt wurde. Nur drei Finger hatten ja immer Scheiße. Ja, und Pest, überall Pest. Ja, lächerlich. Das Ding hat auch Pest, alles Pest. Und tatsächlich hat ein Museumstyp herausgefunden, dass die nichts bauen wollten, was so klingt wie Haydn, sondern die wollten was bauen, die haben sich einen Scherz erlaubt. Die wollten nämlich, dass es spielt, wie ein Mensch nicht spielen könnte. Die wollten ein Gerät bauen, was so schnell das Stück spielt wie Haydn und da kann ich mir vorstellen, wie die so im Kreis saßen. Hey, es kann so schnell spielen, so können wir gar, das ist lächerlich schnell. Das war so der Humor damals einfach. Die wollten einfach ein Gerät bauen, was unmenschlich schnell spielt, und deswegen ist es so hässlich. Aber ich finde es geil, dass er, egal welche Neuigkeit kommt, immer vor dem Problem steht, zu schnell. Es klingt schrecklich. Es klingt schrecklich und zu schnell. Oh Mann, der Arme, ey. Aber er hat das Erfolgserlebnis, er hat herausgefunden, dass die anders notiert haben. Die haben einfach zwei Schläge ist ein Schlag und deswegen ist eigentlich alles wieder ganz okay. Ja, ein grosses geht durch die Niederlande. Wow, bin ich erleichtert. Zum Glück haben wir Leonard Kravitz noch in Originalaufnahme und können tausend Jahre noch gucken, wie hat Lenny's gemacht? Ja, stimmt. Ich kenne keinen einzigen Song von Danny Krivitz. All Along the Watchtower? All Around the Watchtower? Bist du... Sag mal, ein Song von Lenny Kravitz. Zum Beispiel Mix, Playlist. Zuletzt gespielt, Fly Away, Again, I'm Gonna Go My Way, I'll Be Waiting. Die ganzen Hits, American Woman, It Ain't Over Till It's Over, Always on the Run, I Belong to You, Greatest Hits. Er hat alle, wirklich, er hat sie alle gehabt. Cool. Gut, mit dieser kleinen Werkschau von Lenny Kravitz möchten wir uns verabschieden von euch bei diesem Podcast-UFO. Und scheiß, ganz kurz, ich habe in die letzte Folge nochmal reingehört, aus Technikgründen, aus Ego-Gründen, aber in die letzte Folge nicht die Live-Folge, sondern davor die, und sorry, da ist der beste Gag jemals gemacht worden von mir, aller Zeiten, und du bist nicht darauf eingegangen. Es ging nämlich darum, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich noch daran erinnerst, aber es ging darum, dass man beim Physikunterricht Eier aus dem Fenster schmeißt und hast so diese Anedote erzählt, dass es mal jemand einen Propeller drauf gebaut hat und haben wieder diesen Gag gemacht, dass es dann weggeflogen ist und jetzt mittlerweile im All ist. Und ich habe gesagt, ha, und mittlerweile wurde daraus die ISS. Und es ist nicht nur lustig, weil die das Ei immer weiter ausgebaut haben, dass irgendwann eine Raumstation daraus wird, sondern auch weil ISS, weil das Wort Ei darin ist. Dann möchte ich ganz kurz noch nachreichen. ,,Ei". Sehr geil. Also, ihr könnt gerne das Zuhause in die alte Folge schneiden. Unsympathischer Bind. Den Lacher hast du vorhin. Letzte Woche hatte ich einen richtig geilen Gag. So, danke, vielen Dank, tschau, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Kleiner Nachtrag, vielen Dank an Lisa für das Intro. Und jetzt zurück zur Folge. Viel Spaß.